et nous restons dans l'yonne avec andré
villiers pour lui donner en direct
d'austère vous êtes élue ce soir dans
votre canton de joux la ville andré
villiers le président sortant rappelons
le nous avons entendu tout à l'heure
jean baptiste lemoyne pour l'ump se
déclarer candidat également à la
présidence ceux du futur conseil
départemental de l'yonne quelle est
votre réaction
andré villiers bon écoutez c'est un
secret de polichinelle
on entend effectivement depuis quelque
temps la l'éventualité de la candidature
de jean baptiste lemoyne et bien moi je
veut resituer cette candidature dans un
contexte beaucoup plus large qui
indiquent d'abord que nous avons
travaillé pendant quatre ans à restaurer
un certain nombre de situations du
département l'endettement dont je
rappelle qu'il avait doublé dans la
période de 2008 à 2011
nous l'avons stabiliser nous avons
stabilisé également les frais de
personnel puisqu'ils ont baissé de 2 4%
en quatre ans nous diminuons les
dépenses et c'est donc aujourd'hui de
manière parfois même un populaire
puisque nous avons au cours des quatre
années pris des décisions qui ont été la
base de l'argumentaire de nos opposants
de nos opposants socialistes
donc il ya eu un véritable débat
politique à l'échelle à l'échelle les
transports scolaires en particulier mais
la fermeture du laboratoire
départemental encore qui représente un
point unique fiscalité etc etc
donc nous avons créé les conditions
aujourd'hui d'une bonne gestion du
département et dans ce contexte
évidemment j'entends poursuivre cette
cette mission avec un maximum de d'élus
nouveau et puis de ceux qui ont été
reconduits dans leur mandat
donc ça sera l'exercice qui sera proposé
dans dans les jours qui viennent est
confiant je suis très confiant puisque
l'arithmétique me montre que le nombre
de ceux qui manifestent en tout cas leur
soutien à ma candidature m'autorise en
tout cas
a présenté celle ci et je veux vous
annoncer d'ailleurs que cette
candidature sera présentée en séance
plénière jeudi
il n'y aura pas de réunion préalable ce
sera donc une candidature en séance
plénière pour bien montrer que le
l'élection départementale qui a été
présentée par des débats nationaux et
bien a montré en tout cas que lorsque
nous sommes en capacité de nous
organiser pour faire battre le front
national ce qui était le cas puisque je
veux rappeler que dans à peu près 20
précisément seize cantons du département
nous étions duel avec le front national
très équipe de la droite et du centre
étaient concernées trois de gauche et
que globalement et bien à lui une
exception près nous avons gagné toutes
les situations ce qui montre bien que la
stratégie qui a été mise en oeuvre
celle du front républicain que j'ai
initié et bien a permis de sauver en
tout cas un certain nombre de situations
et de conforter la majorité
départementale
donc je suis président cette majorité
départementale et je présente
aujourd'hui un bilan de campagne
extrêmement satisfaisant puisque nous
renforçons cette majorité donc c'est
sans doute le deuxième argument qui me
conduit s'il en fallait un deuxième
voire un troisième à présenter ma
candidature à la poursuite de la
présidence du conseil général et puis
peut-être pour que la coupe soit bien
pleines indiqué que le parlement a voté
une loi qui empêchera de
des 2 cumulé la fonction d'exécutive
départemental avec un mandat
parlementaire et que dans deux ans le
dispositif sera applicable que pour la
première fois dans notre pays l'élection
départementale nous engage non pas pour
trois ans mais pour six ans et que dans
ce contexte là et bien vous voyez aussi
l'intérêt qu'il y a à ce que cette
mission soit poursuivi par par andré
villiers et tous ceux qui le suivront
est-ce que vous avez un mot sur
jean-baptiste lemoyne et sur sa volonté
de présider le conseil général comment
est ce que vous voyez cette candidature
vous non moi je pense que jean baptiste
lemoyne
je pense ce fait une représentation de
la vie publique et de la vie politique
qui est une une représentation dépassé
il voudrait ressembler peut-être à ses
prédécesseurs qui en cumuler cette
fonction parlementaire avec celle de
d'un exécutif et en l'occurrence de
l'exécutif départemental qui aujourd'hui
nos concitoyens veulent des gens qui
soient impliqués au quotidien dans le
terrain savez lorsqu'on déclare par
exemple que à l'occasion de la campagne
électorale on découvre des situations
difficiles que les artisans que les
agriculteurs qu'un grand nombre de
ménages sont à la peine à cause de la
crise et à cause de décisions qui ne
sont pas prises au niveau national
moi j'ai pas besoin de faire campagne
pour cela puisque je vis au milieu des
gens et je sais tout ça au quotidien
donc c'est aussi un élément qui montre
sans doute la différence en termes de
candidature